há anos e sem sucesso. Tentei várias
dietas, tomei medicamentos, meus exames
estão ruins, pré-diabética, problemas no
fígado, trigliceres, colesterol altos,
insulina, são tantos problemas. E eu
resolvi dar mais uma chance. Olá, meu
nome é Sueli e eu confesso a vocês que
eu entrei nesse desafio sem muita
expectativa. Afinal, são tantas
tentativas para conseguir emagrecer e
sem sucesso, mas eu vi o valor e pensei:
"É mais barato que uma pizza. Vou
tentar". Meu nome é Emanuele, eu tenho
42 anos e eu comecei esse desafio
incrédula, porque não é o primeiro
desafio que eu participo na internet,
não é a primeira vez que eu tento uma
dieta e eu já fiz de tudo para
emagrecer, de tudo. E esse ano eu até
coloquei isso no grupo, em uma da das
postagens no Instagram, que esse ano eu
já tinha desistido de começar. E do nada
apareceu uma postagem no meu Instagram,
eu não seguia o Dr. Renan, onde tinha
esse desafio e o que me chamou atenção
foi eliminar até 5 kg em 7 dias. A gente
quando entra na menopausa, a gente
acredita que nada pode ser mudado.
Primeiro que você se sente mal e
sintomas, né, muitos sintomas ruins que
você nunca havia sentido antes. Então
você fica
indisposta até de se cuidar. Você fica
indisposta de cuidar fisicamente, da
saúde, da beleza, de tudo. Você acredita
que nada pode ser mudado? E eu acreditei
e comecei a fazer. Eu nunca imaginei que
eu pudesse passar 20 horas sem me
alimentar. Eu tenho uma compulsão
terrível por alimento, terrível. Eu não
consigo me conter a ponto de ficar
enquanto tô fazendo algo. Eu estou
passeando
pelo meu armário, pela minha geladeira,
tentando encontrar algo para para comer.
Parece que existe uma necessidade, uma
um buraco.
>> Meu nome é Andrelina,
tenho 53 anos, moro em Hortolândia,
estado de São Paulo. difícil no início,
porque eu achei que não ia conseguir a a
chegar até hoje e eu achei que eu não ia
conseguir porque
não tenho mais meu útero, não tenho mais
ovário. Então, no começo, eu achava que
era por causa de não ter mais os
hormônios, né, produzidos pelos ovários.
Aí tive que tirar a vesícula por causa
da pedra na vesícula e aí tudo desandou.
intestino desando, eh, estômago
desandoro, eu não não tinha dor, não
tinha cólica, mas era direto no
banheiro, eu não podia sair porque eu me
preocupava em ir no banheiro, enfim. E
pra minha surpresa, nós estamos no sexto
dia do desafio e eu perdi mais de 4 kg.
Então, eu tô bem satisfeita, tenho
dormido melhor, tenho me sentido mais
desinchada, menos inflamada, então eu só
tenho que agradecer. E eu falei, ó, não
custa, né? Eu vi que o preço era
acessível. Olha,
meu Deus, precisou de 42 anos da minha
vida para em c dias, né, hoje 5 dias eu
aprender mais do que 42 anos sobre o meu
corpo, sobre o meu metabolismo. Isso
abriu uma claridade na minha mente, uma
vontade de mudar, de fazer diferente, de
realmente fazer acontecer e fazer tá
certo. E eu tenho certeza que dessa vez
eu vou conseguir. E hoje com esta última
aula, entendendo melhor sobre os exames,
eu perdi 4, kg. Foi maravilhoso eu
entender que eu ainda estou viva e que
eu mereço estar bem em todos os
sentidos, como na base que ele falou que
são que a base hormonal metabólica, a
alimentação, a mente. Hoje me olho no
espelho com mais satisfação ao ver que
eu consegui eliminar 4 kg de gratidão
eterna, Dr. Renan.
>> Eu tava pesando 81 kg.
e 200 e
agora estou com 79 kg. Eliminei na fita
métrica 8 cm
e é vitória, né?
Para quem não pediu uma grama, obrigada.
>> Olá, meninas. Bom dia, bom dia, bom dia,
bom dia, gente. Sejam muito bem-vindas à
nossa primeira aula do Desafio do jejum.
Sejam muito bem-vindas. Que ó, gente,
essa semana promete e vocês acabaram de
ver, né, depoimentos de algumas mulheres
que chegaram aqui com vocês com dúvida,
com receio. Será que o Dr. Renan vai
aparecer? Não vai. Com todo tipo de
problema de saúde, problema metabólico.
E elas conseguiram. Se elas conseguiram,
vocês também vão conseguir. Então, sejam
muito bem-vindas à nossa primeira aula
do Desafio do jejum. E coloca aqui nos
comentários para mim, gente, de onde que
vocês são, quem aqui tá animada e me
conta. Essa semana vocês vão se
priorizar. Essa semana eu quero que você
se entregue. Essa semana eu quero que
você entenda que
não tem nada que vai tirar o seu foco.
Então coloca isso na sua cabeça, porque
tudo que a gente vai aprender aqui vai
muito além de jejum, vai muito além de
dieta, vai muito além de qualquer coisa
que vocês imaginam que vai ser esse
nosso desafio. Então, sejam muito
bem-vindas. Ó, tô vendo aqui gente de
Jacareí, de Taubaté, de Barbacena,
de Curitiba, de Sorocaba, do Rio de
Janeiro, de
Célia Salgueiro,
eh, de todos os lugares, né, gente, do
Brasil inteiro. Então, olha, sejam muito
bem-vindas, porque essa é a nossa
primeira aula do Desafio do jejum, tem
um universo, um universo sobre saúde que
vocês vão aprender nessa semana. Então,
uma coisa eu posso dar certeza aqui para
vocês. Essa semana não é só sobre jejum.
Essa semana é sobre você, é sobre seu
metabolismo, sobre as tentativas que
você teve até agora de tentar perder
peso que não deram certo. E você vai
entender o porquê de tudo. E quando você
entende o porquê de tudo, não só sobre
erros, mas sobre os seus hormônios,
sobre o seu metabolismo, o que a gente
precisa fazer para para ativar os seus
problemas, os seus problemas metabólicos
para você perder peso de uma vez por
todas. Então, sejam muito bem-vindas,
porque, sim, tem muita coisa para
acontecer nessa semana. Então, eu quero
que nessa semana vocês estejam
presentes, que você se priorize, que
você faça sua parte, porque eu e minha
equipe a gente vai dar 1000% em cima dos
50% que cabe a nossa, mas eu quero que
vocês demem 1000% em cima dos 50% que
cabe a vocês. Portanto, sejam muito
bem-vindas. Começamos a semana com tudo,
com pé direito, porque, ó, uma coisa
aqui vocês podem ter certezas,
uma certezas, uma coisa que vocês podem
ter certeza. Ó, tem gente, acho que da
Holanda, né, que apareceu aqui, ó. Uma
coisa que vocês podem ter certeza,
tudo que vocês vão aprender nessa semana
vai surpreender vocês. E é uma aula
melhor do que a outra. Uma aula melhor
do que a outra. Novamente, escuta o que
eu tô falando e grava isso que eu vou te
falar agora. Esse nosso desafio não é só
sobre jejum.
Não é só sobre jejum. Se você quer fazer
o jejum, é só pegar a dieta na área de
membros e seguir. Mas se você quer
aprender sobre seus hormônios, seu
metabolismo, seus exames, sua saúde e
começar a tratar tudo isso para você ter
o emagrecimento definitivo, isso você só
vai aprender nessas aulas, porque essas
aulas aqui elas são sobre você.
Portanto, sejam muito bem-vindas, porque
começamos com tudo a nossa aula um do
desafio do jejum cinco em sete. Então,
nessa semana vocês vão aprender passos
para vocês emagrecerem até 5 kg nessa
semana. Claro, muitas de vocês vão
emagrecer mais do que 5 kg, outras vão
emagrecer 3,5 kg, 4 kg. Mas eu quero que
vocês entendam o seguinte, essa primeira
semana é a semana do reset, onde a gente
vai dar esse start, a gente vai começar
a tratar sua saúde para você continuar
emagrecendo todos os quilos que você
quiser. E tudo que você vai aprender
aqui, ele foi pautado em mais de 70.000
mulheres que emagreceram com PEF 360,
que é meu programa de emagrecimento
feminino. E mais de 600, escuta o que eu
tô falando, mais de 600.000 1 mulheres
já fizeram o desafio do jejum nos
últimos anos e elas conseguiram eliminar
até 5 kg nesses 7 dias. Mas para você
ter resultado como essas mulheres, você
tem que se comprometer ou você tem que
se hipercrometer, porque as
hipercrometidas são aquelas que vão
estar aqui comigo todos os dias nas
aulas, aprendendo sobre saúde, aplicando
as técnicas e cada uma das aulas vocês
vão receber presentes surpresas. Escuta
o que eu tô falando, gente. Cada uma das
aulas você vão vocês vão ter presentes
durante as aulas. Por isso que eu falo,
é muito importante que vocês estejam nas
aulas, porque tem presentes,
suplementos, metodologias que eu só
libero para quem está na aula. E olha só
isso aqui. Eu quero que vocês olham.
Isso aqui, gente, é para vocês começarem
com gás essa semana. Mulheres que
aplicaram desafio, mulheres que
aplicaram esse desafio, o mesmo desafio
que vocês, com os mesmos problemas que
vocês, elas tiveram resultados como
esse. Olha só, perderam 4, 4,5 kg, 5 kg,
6 kg, eh, 7,g,
5,g 200, 4 kg com mais disposição, com
mais energia, com mais vitalidade,
independente de menopausa, independente
de idade, independente independente dos
problemas de saúde que você tenha. Se
todas elas conseguiram, vocês também
conseguem. Então, olha só, mulheres como
vocês, com todas as tentativas, com
ansiedade, se sentindo para baixo, com
baixa autoestima, não gostando de se
olhar no espelho, não tendo roupa que
fica boa, você tá cheio de roupa no
guarda-roupa. Aliás, vocês escolheram o
amuleto de vocês que eu pedi ontem. Quem
escolheu o amuleto? E olha só, quando
você vê esses depoimentos de mulheres
que já tinham feito bariatra e
conseguiram emagrecer, que já tinham
tinham problema tireoide, dormiam mal,
intestino não funciona, efeito sanfona,
barriga, alteração de fígado,
tomando antidepressivos, anciolíticos,
remédios de pressão, remédio de glicose,
muitas em tratamento de câncer. Se elas
conseguiram esse tipo de resultado,
vocês também vão conseguir. Mas não é
milagre, é metodologia.
Não é milagre. Então sei que você chega
aqui e fala: "Ah, Dr. Henão, mas já
passei dos 40, 50, 60, 70 anos. Será que
para mim vai funcionar?" Claro que vai
funcionar. Tá aqui a prova mulheres de
todas as idades com todos os tipos de
problemas que conseguiram esses
resultados aqui. Mas novamente, não é
milagre. Eu quero que você esteja aqui
comigo todos os dias, porque olha,
quando você vê, nossa, perdi, meu Deus,
tô renando, perdi 4 kg na semana, 5 kg,
6 kg, é um baita resultado. Mas o que
que tem por trás desse resultado? Não é
só dieta. É você ter uma compreensão
mais aprofundada sobre os seus
hormônios, sobre seu metabolismo, sobre
a sua saúde. Porque o emagrecimento
definitivo, ele depende de você dar 200%
em cima dos 50% cabe a você. Não se
esqueçam disso que eu vou falar aqui
agora. É uma via de mão dupla. Eu vou
estar aqui com vocês todos os dias ao
vivo 7 horas da manhã. Todos os dias ao
vivo, 7 horas da manhã.
Então, quero que você se comprometa
comigo, quero que você esteja comigo
aqui todo dia e vai valer a pena porque
quando a gente chegar lá no final de
semana vocês vão ver que fez assim, ó.
Pá, passou, gente. É impressionante.
Vocês vão ver se passou. E vocês vão me
contar isso depois, porque olha,
essa via de mão dupla, a gente vai te
entregar a melhor estratégia, o nível de
conhecimento que vocês nunca tiveram
sobre vocês. Novamente, quem chegou aqui
agora, esse nosso esse nosso desafio do
jejum, ele não é sobre
ele não é sobre
somente o jejum, porque eu sei que vocês
entram aqui, né, pelo valor simbólico
que vocês investiram para fazer parte.
Ah, será que o Dr. Renan vai est? Será
que ele não vai est? Será que ele vai
vir ao vivo? Será que não vai? Eu tô
aqui ao vivo com vocês. Mas essas aulas
elas são sobre você. Eu vou te ensinar a
analisar os seus hormônios, a sua saúde.
Teremos no final da semana uma aula
sobre exames. Teremos aula sobre
suplementação, sobre seus hormônios,
técnicas, suplementos, tratamentos para
você cuidar da sua saúde de uma forma
integral. Porque é isso que vai ser o
divisor de águas, não só para você
emagrecer seus quilos aqui na semana,
mas para você ter saúde, para você viver
bem, ter mais energia, mais vitalidade e
se todas elas conseguiram resultados
independente de tudo isso, vocês também
vão conseguir, gente. Então vamos lá. O
que que te aguarda aqui na nossa
primeira aula, gente? Então quero aqui
todo dia, todo mundo aqui comigo todos
os dias.
Hoje vamos falar dúvidas que vocês podem
ter no seu jejum, mais alguns segredos.
Vou te mostrar os cinco erros que te
impedem de emagrecer. Vou te mostrar a
escada do emagrecimento.
Vamos te mostrar hoje três vias de
ativação do seu metabolismo. E quando eu
mostrar essas três vias, eu quero que
todo mundo prepara o print aí do
celular, tira a foto, porque eh são
técnicas que você já consegue
implementar hoje para acelerar
emagrecimento. Vou te entregar a
primeira chave secreta e o primeiro
bônus acelerador de metabolismo. O que
que é essa chave secreta? Cada uma das
aulas, gente, presta atenção. Cada uma
das aulas eu vou liberar no final chave
secreta. Essas chaves são o quê? São
materiais,
análises individualizadas
e só para quem tiver na aula que vai
receber essa chave secreta. E tem o
bônus de cada aula. Cada uma nas cada
uma das aulas eu vou liberar bônus. E
esses bônus t relação com técnicas
também, suplementos que aceleram sua
saúde, acelera seu emagrecimento,
aceleram seu metabolismo. E esses bônus
só recebe quem tiver nas aulas. Mas eu
pedi para vocês algumas coisas, vocês
preencheram, né? Vocês fizeram a análise
lá do questionário que eu pedi para
vocês, não fizeram o questionário?
Fizeram, né? questionário. Coloca aqui
para mim quem é que preencheu aquele
questionário. Eu pedi para que cada um
de vocês escrevesse uma carta pro seu eu
do futuro. Quem é que escreveu essa
carta? Quem é que escreveu?
Quando eu pedi para você escrever essa
carta do futuro, do futuro, quando você
escreve, grava isso que eu tô falando,
está lá em Abacuk,
é na Bíblia e é comprovado pela
neurociência. Quando você escreve, tudo
que você escreve se manifesta na sua
vida de uma forma muito mais rápida,
muito mais fluida. Então eu pedi que
você escrevesse é uma carta para essa
mulher do futuro.
E aí
o que mais apareceu, eu fiquei tão
surpreso porque foi o seguinte, o que
mais apareceu pra gente não foi quero
emagrecer tantos quilos, quero ficar
mais bonito, não sabe o que que vocês
contaram ali para mim? que vocês buscam
mais leveza, menos peso, mais energia,
mais disposição. E isso foi uma surpresa
pra gente. Quando eu peguei a análise de
todos esses dados, eu falei assim: "Que
legal isso, né? Como que tá a
mentalidade dessas mulheres?" Sabe por
quê? Porque quando você fala: "Olha, eu
eu não me reconheço mais. Eu quero
voltar a me reconhecer. Eu não reconheço
o meu corpo, eu não me sinto bonita, eu
quero ter mais vitalidade, eu quero
viver mais, viver melhor. Então isso já
mostra uma maturidade de consciência que
é muito difícil de ter, porque muitas
mulheres quando buscam emagrecimento,
elas são imediatistas, elas são mais
impulsivas, elas querem algo fácil que
dê resultado, mas não. Essa turma me
surpreendeu positivamente, porque vocês
estão com uma consciência de querer
viver mais, de viver melhor, de querer
construir uma saúde plena. Porque é
isso? Porque o peso ele é apenas um
número. Mas o como que você se sente?
Porque você sente frustrada por não
conseguir, baixa autoestima. Você não
gosta de te olhar no espelho, você vai
numa loja e não tem a roupa que a roupa
que você gosta não serve, você tem que
comprar a roupa que dá. Eu sei o quanto
isso dói, eu sei o quanto isso te afeta.
E a gente vai começar a tratar tudo isso
aqui nessa semana, inclusive a sua
mentalidade. Então, quero que você hoje
comece nesse reencontro com você mesma,
porque independente de peso,
independente do seu corpo, você, mesmo
você estando com baixa autoestima, mesmo
você que já tentou muitas coisas, eu
quero que você entenda que é possível,
que existe uma mulher aí dentro que tem
valor. Porque se você começa a olhar só
os defeitos, digamos assim, se você
começa a olhar só com um olhar de
autocrítica o tempo todo, se você não
consegue nem se olhar, vai ser muito
difícil você reconstruir essa relação
com o seu corpo, porque eu sei que você
tá cansada de esperar, eu sei que você
tá cansada de tentar. E talvez você até
já falou para você mesma que, ah, eu vou
tentar me aceitar assim,
porque você tá cansada. Mas eu quero te
falar uma coisa,
esse seu cansaço, ele tem motivo, ele é
real, mas a culpa não é sua.
Então esse é o tom que eu quero
estabelecer aqui com vocês, o acordo que
eu quero estabelecer com você aqui. A
culpa do seu sobrepeso não é sua. Você
não tem culpa do seu excesso de peso.
Grava isso mais uma vez. A culpa não é
sua. E eu vou te provar que a culpa não
é sua nessa semana. Eu vou te provar que
a culpa não é sua.
Então, quando você fala isso aqui para
mim, ah, tupar minha autoestima, quero
que as minhas roupas voltam a voltem a
servir, quero mais saúde, bem-estar.
Isso mostra essa consciência.
E aí vocês escreveram isso aqui pra
gente.
Isso aqui são frases de cartas de vocês,
hein, que a gente teve acesso.
Você escreveu para mim: "Vou me
reconhecer novamente ao melhor no
espelho". Isso é muito profundo, sabe?
Você
chegou num ponto que você não se
reconhece mais.
Uma outra aluna falou assim: "Eu vou ter
a minha vida de volta. Eu cansei de
esperar a minha vez." E eu quero falar
uma coisa para vocês que vocês nunca
podem esquecer. A família também sofre
junto.
A família também sofre junto. Por mais
que a família finja que nada tá
acontecendo com você, a família também
sofre junto.
Porque hoje você não tem energia para
brincar com filho, para brincar com
neto.
Você não gosta de tirar uma foto. E aí
você vai e fala ali para mim: "Nossa, eu
quero ter mais energia para brincar com
minhas filhas. Quero olhar sem medo no
espelho".
Então, daqui a 7 dias,
o que que vai ser diferente na sua vida
se você perder seus 3, 4, 5, 6 kg?
Sabe o que que vai ser diferente?
Não vai ser só números na balança,
vai ser diferente o nível de
conhecimento que você vai ter, o
tratamento que a gente vai começar a
fazer da causa raiz dos seus problemas.
a gente vai começar a controlar a
ansiedade, vamos começar a recuperar
autoestima, vamos reconstruir essa essa
reconexão com o seu corpo, porque
novamente você não tem culpa do peso que
você tá. Nossa, Dr. Renan, mas eu ouço
falar todo mundo que é porque eu como
errado, que é por causa da minha
genética. Não, você vai entender que
existem problemas hormonais nessa semana
que você não escolheu. Eu te pergunto,
você escolheu dormir mal? Você escolheu
ter problema de tireoide?
Você escolheu ter o intestino preso?
Você escolheu ter resistência
insulínica? Não, você não escolheu nada
disso. São problemas que apareceram. Ah,
você escolheu entrar na menopausa, não.
Então, a gente vai começar a cuidar de
tudo isso de uma forma integrada e você
vai tirar esse peso das costas, a culpa,
porque você não tem culpa do excesso de
peso que você tem. Claro, a gente tem
que entender que teve vezes que você se
abandonou, tá? Não vou passar tanto
pano, né? Vou passar pano assim para
vocês também, não, tá? a gente vai ter
que assumir essa nossa responsabilidade.
Mas mais de 90% de vocês aqui não tem
culpa nenhuma do excesso de peso. E aí
eu perguntei isso aqui. Amuleto. Quem é
que escolheu amuleto, gente? Calça jeans
foi o número um, assim, disparado,
disparado. Aí vestido, depois vestido,
depois roupa de um casamento,
depois blusa, camisa, mas assim,
calça jeans lá em cima. Então, você quer
escolher o seu amuleto, qual que a
importância de você deixar o seu amuleto
à vista? Eu quero que você deixe o
amuleto à vista porque eu preciso
colocar um despertador no seu cérebro. E
todos os dias quando você vê essa roupa,
por que que eu preciso que essa roupa
esteja à vista para que você veja todos
os dias e que você lembre todos os dias
o por que aquela roupa tá ali? Não, não
é a roupa que importa,
é a mulher que vai entrar naquela roupa
que importa.
E o que que essa mulher que vai entrar
naquela roupa precisa fazer? Se
priorizar, se cuidar, seguir toda a
estratégia. E eu tô te pedindo uma
semana, gente. O que que é uma semana da
sua vida? Para você ter um nível de
conhecimento que nenhuma consulta médica
que você foi até hoje te deu. E eu vou
te dar. Só que eu não vou te dar só
conhecimento, eu vou te dar ferramentas,
eu vou te dar estratégias, eu vou te dar
metodologia, eu vou te dar eh dicas de
de suplementos, de de de tratamentos, de
tudo. Então, essa semana vale mais do
que qualquer consulta que você passou
até hoje, mas você vai ter que fazer sua
parte porque não existe milagre aqui.
Não existe milagre. E aí eu perguntei
isso aqui para vocês, né?
Aí teve uma que falou assim: "Quando eu
entrar nessa roupa, eu vou sentir que eu
venci". O que que vai, o que que você
vai sentir quando você entrar no seu
amuleto? O que que você vai sentir?
Coloca aqui nos comentários para mim o
que que você vai sentir. O que que O que
que vai vir de sensação de emoção para
você?
Ó lá, alguém falou: "Ecolhi um vestido
que fica muito justo. Quero ver ele
soltinho". E é isso. O que que significa
para você entrar nessa roupa, nesse
amuleto?
Não é sobre a roupa, é sobre a mulher
que vai entrar. lá realizada,
satisfação,
muita felicidade,
realizada, bem-estar. E junto com
bem-estar vem saúde plena,
né? Autoestima elevada, significa saúde,
libertação, vitória, satisfação.
É isso, meninas.
Vamos ver em camadas um pouquinho mais
profundas por trás desse amuleto. Não é
sobre a roupa, é sobre você.
E os principais motivos de vocês estarem
aqui nessa semana, qual que foi? Saúde
em primeiro. Gente, eu tô tão, eu tô tão
feliz assim com essa turma, porque
normalmente as mulheres entram aqui, só
quero quilos na balança, Dr. Renan, só
quero ficar magra, só quero ficar
bonita. Não.
Primeira vez que aparece saúde em
primeiro lugar.
É muito legal porque o trabalho que a
gente faz aqui de conscientização,
eu falo sobre emagrecimento porque
emagrecimento eu sei que faz isso vocês
quererem se cuidar mais, mas quando eu
vejo vocês falando de saúde em primeiro
lugar, é um nível de consciência dessa
turma que eu nunca vi antes. Porque a
gente tá pensando o quê? Em longevidade
saudável, em viver mais, em viver
melhor, depois veio emagrecer e perder
barriga. Claro, emagrecer, perder
barriga é muito bom, é importante, a
gente vai construir tudo isso aqui. E
vocês fizeram parte dessa dessa nossa
pesquisa e muito obrigado por isso,
porque
isso faz a gente ir para um outro
caminho aqui com vocês.
E aí o momento, né? O que que foi o
ponto de virada, né, que fez cada uma de
vocês decidirem. Pera aí, eu quero me
cuidar.
Olha só, que que vocês contaram para
mim, Dr. Renão, tô cansada de dieta. Eu
emagreço e quando volto a comer, eu
recupero tudo. Eu coloquei minhas fichas
nesse método. Ah, eu comprei esse
desafio porque eu mereço viver com
saúde.
Uma outra aluna falou assim, ó: "Se eu
destravar meu emagrecimento em uma
semana, eu vou acreditar que eu posso
chegar no meu peso."
Uma outra al falou: "Quero andar sem
medo de cair por causa do peso. Meus
joelhos já não aguentam mais". Sabe is
que que isso aqui reflete?
Primeiro, o cansaço que todas vocês têm.
Cada vez que você sofre com efeito
sanfona, você piora problemas hormonais
e metabólicos.
Então esse cansaço, ele não é só físico,
ele é emocional, porque você tenta, eu
sei que você vai em médico, eu sei que
você vai nutrire, eu sei que você faz
dieta, eu sei que você come pouco.
Quando você fala para mim, torna, mas eu
como pouco e não perco peso, eu
acredito, tá? Eu acredito. Eu sei que o
muitos profissionais que vocês vão,
quando você conta isso, eles não
acreditam não. Provavelmente falam que
você tá comendo errado. Mas você vai
entender nessa semana o quão os seus
problemas hormonais impactam no seu
metabolismo.
Então esse cansaço, ele chega um ponto
que você fala: "Ah, vou me aceitar do
jeito que eu tô". Mas eu pergunto, você
quer se aceitar do jeito que você tá?
Essa é uma pergunta muito importante.
Você tá feliz do jeito que você tá? Eu
sei que se você destravar seu
emagrecimento na semana, não vai ser só
relacionado ao jejum, vai ser sobre a
construção em cima de um ponto que se
chama base hormonal metabólica, que
vocês vão aprender. E foi exatamente
isso que a gente fez com a Cris, a Cris,
pós-menopausa, todos os problemas de
saúde, gordura no fígado, obesidade e
pré-diabete, tireoide desregulada,
ansiedade, baixa autoestima. Ela chegou:
"Ai, gente, tô vai me aceitar assim, só
que você não aceita, né?
E aí a Cris, falei: "Cris, você não tem
culpa, não é menopausa, vamos lá, vamos
cuidar desses problemas hormonais,
cuidar da gordura no fígado, cuidado da
glicose, cuidar da insulina, vamos
cuidar da sua tireoide".
33 kg eliminados. 33 kg eliminados em 4
meses, sendo 13 kg em 45 dias.
Então não tem esse papo de, ah, meu
problema é idade, com a idade fica mais
difícil, eu tenho um monte de problema
de saúde, fica mais difícil. Não fica. E
eu vou te explicar como que a gente
constrói tudo isso no detalhe. Só que
hoje vocês estão aqui porque eu quebrei
a cara com a medicina, tá, meninas?
Então, quando vocês me veem aqui, vem o
Dr. Renan de rede social, gente, eu sou
formado em medicina, sou médico há vou
vai fazer 13 anos. 13 anos. E eu fiz
especialização em nutrologia,
endocrinologia, prática ortomolecular,
medicina integrativa, homeostase
endócrina. E aí depois eu fui para áreas
da nutrição, nutrição esportiva,
nutrição estética, nutrição funcional e
algumas outras medicinas alternativas,
medicina chinesa, medicina a base da
medicina aa. Então, quando a gente junta
todas essas medicinas, a gente consegue
ter uma visão ampla de todos os aspectos
da saúde, não só sobre análise de
exames, te passa um remédio, te manda
para casa, não. E é claro, a medicina
tradicional ela é importante também.
Existe um conceito muito errado que eu
vejo muitos profissionais que se dizem
médicos integrativos na internet, quer
falar mal da medicina tradicional e a
gente não pode falar mal porque a gente
precisa dessa medicina. Todas as
medicinas elas precisam trabalhar
juntas. Só que lá atrás, gente, eu não
era esse médico, eu não tinha esse
conhecimento. Eu aplicava o que eu
aprendi com meus professores, alguns
professores lá no começo, super
tradicionais. Então, quebrei a cara com
a medicina. Sabe por quê? Porque lá
atrás eu era esse médico que passava
remédio. Então assim, eu eu não tenho
vergonha de falar de isso porque eu
aprendi com isso, né? E eu só tô aqui.
Eu só tô aqui.
Tem que, ó, Gabriela falou: "Vamos
começar que hora? Só enrolou.
A gente precisa mudar essa mentalidade,
tá, Gabriela? Mas vai valer a pena cada
segundo que você vai estar aqui, viu?
E eu quero que vocês estejam presentes
nessa semana, sabe por quê? Porque é
sobre vocês, tá bom? É sobre vocês.
Porque eu quebrei a cara com a medicina
lá atrás. Eu era esse médico, igual
algumas de vocês que fica sem paciência,
né? Eu que queria passar remédio,
passava remédio pros pacientes lá atrás,
8 anos atrás, né? 9 anos atrás. 9 13 10
anos atrás. 10 9 anos atrás. Eu passava
cbotramina, saxenda, victosa naquela não
existia os pique, não existia monjara
naquela época, né? Eu era esse médico,
só que os pacientes voltavam,
emagreciam, alguns não emagreciam e
depois e alguns depois tinham um reganho
de peso quando parava com a medicação.
Então assim, eu falo: "Pera aí, tudo que
eu tô aprendendo lá naquela época, que
era um conhecimento inicial relacionado
a isso, não tava dando resultado para
todo mundo.
Não tava dando resultado para todo
mundo. Eu falei: "Pera aí, tem alguma
coisa muito errada aqui, né?" E porque
eu tava fazendo o que todos os
profissionais faziam. Eu fazia o que
todos os profissionais faziam, mas eu
falei, será que eu segui essa manada que
vai dar resultado? E aí eu lembrava,
lembrei de uma frase, né, do Dr. Cícero,
que era um professor meu, e ele falava
assim: "Vocês precisam gravar duas
coisas. A clínica é soberana e nosso
corpo se adapta a tudo". Então eu ficava
com essa frase na cabeça. E quando eu
comecei a fazer um curso de de era uma
pó depois da nutrologia, tinha um outro
curso de especialização em fisiologia e
aí o professor falou essa essa essa
frase, falou a mesma coisa que o Dr.
Cícero da faculdade e aí me veio ele na
cabeça, a clínica é soberana. Seus
sintomas me falam muito mais sobre você.
Seus sintomas me falam muito mais sobre
você do que números no papel de
laboratório. Então, se você chega para
mim cansado, fadigado, unha fraca, queda
de cabelo, metabolismo lento, barriga,
efeito sanfona, intestino não funciona,
preguiça, desânimo, oscilação de humor,
depressão, ansiedade, você não perde
peso, comendo pouco, muita vontade de
doce ou pouca fome, você tem problemas
hormonais que às vezes não mostram no
seus exames. Então, você vai lá, faz o
exame, tá aparentemente OK. E essa
semana, no final da semana, eu vou
aprender vocês a analisarem os exames de
vocês. Tanto é que eu vou querer todo
pega os exames aí que vocês têm para
vocês aprenderem olhar. No final da
semana eu vou explicar tudo. Então
aquilo me despertou. Falei: "Pera aí, eu
tô analisando exames sendo que eu tenho
que analisar sintomas". Isso, gente, há
10 anos atrás. E aí essa outra frase, o
nosso corpo se adapta a tudo. Quando o
paciente, você vai lá no nutricionista,
pode ser o melhor nutricionista da
sociedade, você sai com uma dieta e fica
com aquela dieta dois meses, seu corpo
adapta. Eu falei assim, se eu começar
trocar de estratégia, trocar de
tratamento antes do corpo se adaptar, se
o nosso corpo se adapta a tudo, então eu
preciso fazer essas trocas. E aí eu fui
testando isso. Então isso aqui foi o
grande divisor de águas. Inclusive é
isso que vocês estão fazendo aqui. Isso,
gente, tô falando de 10 anos atrás.
Vocês nessa semana cada dia é uma
estratégia diferente. Vocês vão
aprendendo técnicas todos os dias
diferentes para ir aplicando. E a gente
vai fazendo toda essa essa ciclagem, uma
análise de seus sintomas.
E aí isso aqui, olha só,
me fez criar um um uma outro um outro
nível de estratégia, porque são as
dificuldades, quando a gente se se
depara com essas dificuldades que a
gente tem quebrar essas barreiras, sabe?
Nessas dificuldades a gente tem quebrar
essas barreiras e ver, pera aí, por que
que eu tô com dificuldade? Será que você
quer um sinal para eu ir para outro,
para outro caminho? Então, comecei a
analisar os pacientes. Eu peguei os
pacientes, o normal, como é que era?
Você pega um paciente que tem resultado
e você replica aquele tratamento para as
pessoas.
Mas aquilo não fazia sentido na minha
cabeça. Falei assim, pera aí, eu preciso
pegar quem não tá tendo resultado e
entender no detalhe o que tá acontecendo
com essa pessoa. Então peguei os
pacientes que não tinham resultados,
comecei a fazer mapeamento de sintoma
com mapeamento de exame.
E aí eu comecei a a a quebrar minha
cabeça com uma coisa que era aqueles
parâmetros de normalidade de
laboratório. Aqueles parâmetros de
normalidade de laboratório não servem
para nada. Só que o médico fala para
você que tá tudo bem e não tá.
Então eu comecei a pegar os exames e
deixar em níveis ótimos. Por exemplo,
exame de TSH. Se você tiver exame de
TSH, quem aqui tiver exame de TSH?
TSH,
TSH, o exame perfeito, tem que ser
abaixo de 2,2.
TSH tem que ser abaixo de 2,2, meninas.
Para quem quer emagrecer,
TSH tem que ser abaixo de 2,2.
Se não, se tiver de 2.3 para cima, não
perde peso. E eu comecei a analisar
exames e deixar exames em níveis ótimos,
não naquele parâmetro de normalidade. Eu
comecei a pegar dieta, ao invés de
passar uma dieta, comecei a trocar de
dieta semanalmente e depois eu peguei o
mapeamento dos sintomas. Pera aí, tá
cansada? Vamos acabar com cansaço. Você
tá com queda de cabelo, unha fraca,
vamos otimizar e entender o que que tá
acontecendo. Você tá com efeito sanfona,
tá com barriga. O que que tem relação
com a barriga? cortisol, insulina,
fígado. Então aqui eu comecei a mapear
os sintomas e fazer todo esse tipo de
tratamento nesses três pilares aqui. E
aí o resultado surreal que eu nunca
tinha tido em consultório antes. As
pacientes começaram a perder 10, 15, 20
kg em 45 dias. Imagina você perdendo 10
kg, 15 kg, 20 kg em 45 dias. você volta
a se amar, recupera autoestima, gosta,
volta a gostar do espelho, para de
esconder nas fotos, volta a ter mais
energia, mais disposição,
entende? Então assim, eu não quero que
vocês pensem que, ah, meu Deus do céu,
então eu preciso viver de jejum para
sempre. Não, o jejum é uma das
estratégias. Ah, mas eu vou ter que
cortar meu queijinho, que eu gosto, meu
pão. Não, gente, dá para você ter uma
alimentação equilibrada com tudo que
você gosta dentro dessas estratégias
para você ter resultado assim. Mas isso
aqui, claro, é uma metodologia que vocês
vão aprender ao longo dessa semana.
Então, quero que vocês sintam-se
privilegiados por vocês estarem aqui,
porque tudo que vocês vão aplicar nessa
semana foi em cima desses 13 anos
trabalhando com emagrecimento e
desenvolvendo eh toda essa estratégia.
que foi desenvolvida a partir do momento
que eu quebrei cara lá atrás. E aí
aquilo me despertou assim, porque eu
falei, gente, remédio não emagrece
ninguém. Isso. Ah, 9 anos atrás. Remédio
não emagrece, remédio só tira fome.
Remédio não cuida dos seus hormônios,
não cuida do seu metabolismo. Então
vocês estão aqui pelo valor simbólico
que vocês investiram e vocês fazem parte
do nosso propósito de levar saúde, levar
conhecimento pro maior número de pessoas
que a gente consegue. E você tá aqui
comigo 7 horas da manhã, você se colocou
como prioridade e eu te agradeço por
isso. Muito, muito, muito obrigado. Mas
você vai ter que fazer sua parte. E
sobre esse mapeamento de sintomas que
hoje eu vou liberar para vocês, a nossa
primeira chave secreta,
acabei de falar para vocês, para perder
peso, para ter saúde, primeiro tem que
fazer um mapeamento de sintomas. E cada
uma dessas aulas, eu vou liberar ao
final das aulas algumas chaves secretas.
Então, a primeira chave secreta que
vocês vão ganhar hoje é o mapeamento
completo dos seus sintomas e dos seus
hormônios. será liberado no final da
nossa aula. E cada uma das aulas eu vou
liberando novas chaves, técnicas,
tratamentos, materiais secretos,
análises. Então assim, isso daqui,
gente, vocês vão ter cada chave dessa
vale uma consulta, como você passasse
uma consulta. E vocês vão ter acesso a
tudo isso aqui. Eu vou liberar no final
todo esse mapeamento de presente para
vocês. E quem tiver hoje na aula, eu
libero,
só para quem tá na aula, bônus. Olha só,
eu criei um protocolo acelera
metabolismo e cada e cada peça desse
protocolo, nós temos sete peças e cada
uma das aulas eu vou liberando uma peça
desse protocolo para acelerar seu
metabolismo. Só que ele é entregue
somente para quem estiver na aula. É um
bônus secreto. E esses e esse e esse
bônus de cada aula, ele acelera seu
metabolismo, melhora seus resultados. E
eu não posso revelar muito só ao final
da aula. Quem tiver aqui comigo, vocês
ganham. Então, temos dois presentes
para quem tá aqui hoje. Em cada uma das
aulas, vocês vão receber esses
presentes. Então, serão sete peças de um
protocolo chamado protocolo Acelera
metabolismo. Gente, isso aqui é coisa
prática, tá? Em uma peça dessa já
começa, já pode aplicar hoje, já pode
começar a colocar em prática na sua
rotina.
Entendidos? Então, vamos lá. Dúvidas do
jejum de vocês. Dr. Renan, posso fazer
atividade física em jejum? Pode fazer
atividade física em jejum sem nenhum
problema. Ah, mas não vou perder massa
magra, gente. Uma semana. Não tem como
você perder massa magra mesmo, porque a
gente tá fazendo uma estratégia onde
vocês têm consumo de proteína, preserva
a massa magra, vocês perdem gordura.
Pode quebrar o jejum com carboidrato?
Porque eu vi alguém falando que não pode
quebrar jejum com carboidrato. Depende
do tipo de jejum, depende do horário. Se
você faz um jejum de 18 horas, 20 horas,
então não é interessante você quebrar o
jejum, fazer a primeira refeição do
jejum com carboidrato. Mas uma
estratégia que vocês faram hoje que é 14
horas, então sim, pode um jejum de 16
horas, pode também quebrar com
carboidrato complexo. Pode beber líquido
nas refeições, pode beber líquido nas
refeições, não vai engordar, não vai dar
barriga. Fiquem tranquilas.
Única situação que eu recomendo vocês
retirarem líquido das refeições, sabe
qual que é? Quem tem má digestão. Se
você tem má digestão, a barriga fica
distendida, quando você bebe líquido,
esse líquido ele vai diluir o suco
gástrico. Então sua digestão vai ficar o
quê? Comprometida.
Ah, torre, não, tô com fome. O que
fazer? Normalmente a pessoa, quem que
vai ter mais dor de cabeça, fome? São as
pessoas que tm um grau elevado de
resistência à insulina.
Então, quem tem resistência insulínica
vai ter uma dorzinha de cabeça, vai ter
fome, se preciso, pode tomar um
remedinho para dor de cabeça. Mas um
segredo aqui, no período de jejum, água
com pitadinha de sal, isso vai te jogar
para cima e vai evitar dor de cabeça.
Teve fome, ó, gente, amanhã, depois de
amanhã, você vai ver que você vai ter
menos fome, mais energia, mais
disposição.
alguns segredos aqui. Então, essas esse
segredo da água com sal, isso aqui é
imprescindível. Isso aqui vai trazer um
bem-estar para quem tem dificuldade de
fazer jejum,
te dá energia, te dá disposição, ajuda a
prevenir essa dor de cabeça.
Posso tomar shot de imunidade eh em
jejum? Água com limão, canela, cúrcuma,
própolis? Não, isso vai quebrar o seu
jejum. Posso manter os meus remédios que
eu faço uso? Sim, pode manter suas
medicações. Não é para suspender
medicação.
Posso fazer mais do que 14 horas hoje?
Não pode, porque nós estamos em uma
estratégia progressiva de jejum. Se você
fizer mais horas de jejum, você vai
estragar o que a gente tá construindo.
Porque eu preciso fazer essa escalada de
estratégia para você ter mais resultado.
Para você ter mais resultado.
Essa água com sal não vai alterar quem
tem pressão alta? Não, gente, é uma
pitadinha, tem que ser sal integral. Se
for o sal integral, uma pitadinha, não
vai aumentar pressão. Pode ficar
tranquila, viu? Pode ficar tranquila.
Chá pode jejum, pode. Chimarrão pode
jejum, pode. Sem nenhum problema.
Ah, Dr. Renando, tenho um soninho. Posso
dormir à tarde? Pode, não tem nenhum
problema. Que que pode consumir em
jejum? Água, chás, café, sem nenhum
problema. Perfeito. Agora sim, gente,
vamos lá. Líquidos permitidos,
proibidos, estão dentro dos materiais da
nossa área de membros. Tá lá na sua
dieta. Se você ler a dieta, tá tudo
explicado lá. Água com limão não pode.
Água com limão não pode em jejum. Café
pode, só não pode com açúcar. Adoçantes
permitidos no período de jejum,
preferencialmente stévia.
Preferencialmente stévia. Água com o a
pitada sal. Um copo de água, gente. Um
copo de água pitadinha. pitadinha. Mas
olha, essas perguntas que vocês estão
fazendo aqui no chat, tá tudo detalhado
nos materiais, tá tudo detalhado na
dieta de vocês. Deixa eu mostrar para
vocês. Então, vamos dar uma olhadinha
aqui nos materiais.
Entendido?
Obrigado, meninas. Vamos lá. Deixa eu
compartilhar uma tela aqui com vocês.
Opa, aqui.
Então, vamos lá.
Deixa eu só compartilhar uma tela aqui
da nossa área de membros.
Foi. Ah, achei. Hum.
Então aqui aqui nós temos a nossa área
de membros.
É muito importante que você entre no
grupo VIP WhatsApp, responda o
questionário. Aqui nós temos a todas as
aulas. Eu quero que você ative o
lembrete de todas essas aulas para você
não perder nenhuma delas. Lembrando que
quem tá ao vivo na aula, a gente tem, a
gente tem os presentes, tem essa aula
bônus aqui para você preencher sua carta
que eu falei para vocês, as aulas
pré-desafio e aqui todos os materiais.
Quer saber como tudo vai funcionar,
gente? Acessa o cronograma, olha o
cronograma direitinho. Ah, torre, não,
não sei qual minha dieta. Tá aqui, ó. Só
clicar aqui, como escolher sua dieta. E
aí, depois de escolher sua dieta, vai
ter as cores da dieta, vai sair a cor da
sua dieta. Se você for vegana,
vegetariana, ah, eu sou vegetariana,
posso transitar entre a vegana e a
normal? Pode, sem nenhum problema. Tem
aqui, ó, ebook de chás naturais,
receitas para molhos e essas cinco
técnicas metabólicas para emagrecer
tomando água. Eu quero que todos vocês
acessem isso. Isso aqui aumenta seu
metabolismo em 30%.
Em 30%. Aqui, ó, bebidas e adoçantes
permitidos durante o desafio. Lista
completa de temperos, tudo que você
precisa tá aqui. Vamos acessar o
cronograma, só que eu quero compartilhar
uma coisa com vocês. Então, aqui nós
temos o cronograma completo do nosso
desafio, né? Tudo bonitinho, que pode, o
que não pode, anela de proteína. Então,
o dia um aqui, ó, primeira refeição, né?
esse carboidrato, depois com o
carboidrato, tudo organizado para vocês,
mas eu quero principalmente essa parte
aqui.
Essa página é muito importante,
por Vamos lá. Aqui eu coloquei opções
para vocês.
14 horas de jejum. Se você iniciar 4 da
tarde, ah, eu gosto de fazer minha
última refeição, 4 da tarde, tô Renan,
16 horas.
Então, sua primeira refeição, quando
você faz jejum de 14 horas
às 6, quando você fizer 16 horas de
jejum, que é amanhã, depois de amanhã,
você faz a primeira refeição do dia às 8
da manhã. Entendido, gente? Deixa eu
repetir aqui.
Aqui eu coloquei opções
de pessoas que gostam de fazer a última
refeição do dia mais cedo. Tem gente que
gosta de fazer a última refeição, 3 da
tarde. Temos alunas, por exemplo, que
trabalham à noite. Tem gente que gosta
de fazer a última refeição do dia, 5 da
tarde. Tem gente que gosta de fazer a
última refeição do dia, 6 da tarde. Tem
gente que gosta de fazer a última
refeição do dia, 20 horas. Se você fizer
sua última refeição do dia às 20 horas,
quando você fizer o jejum de 14 horas, a
primeira refeição do dia seguinte vai
ser às 10. Quando for jejum de 16 horas,
a primeira refeição do dia seguinte vai
ser às 12. Quando for jejum de 18 horas,
ser às 14. Quando for jejum de 20 horas,
primeira refeição do dia seguinte vai
ser às 16. Entendido? Então, tá tudo
organizado aqui para vocês. Vamos agora
voltar aqui
então. OK. Tem um cronograma, como
escolher a dieta, tudo bonitinho. E aqui
embaixo nós temos os e-books
complementares para vocês. Isso aqui não
é obrigatório, são presentes incríveis.
Olha que linda a nossa plataforma toda
lindona, cheia de materiais incríveis
para vocês. Aproveitem esses materiais.
Perfeito. Então, queria mostrar
principalmente o cronograma, porque ele
no cronograma já tem organização, quando
você pode escolher: "Ah, mas um dia eu
quero fazer minha última refeição às 20
horas, outro dia eu quero fazer 5 da
tarde." Você pode fazer essa alteração
sem nenhum problema. Você pode ajustar
de acordo com a sua rotina. Então ali
nós temos líquidos permitidos,
proibidos, tá tudo ali. Tudo que você
precisa saber sobre jejum tá na área de
membros. Tudo que você precisa saber
sobre você, seus hormônios, metabolismo,
tratamento, serão nessas aulas. E o que
tem nessas aulas não tem dentro da nossa
área de membros. Novamente, repetindo,
muita gente chegou depois. Essas aulas
elas são sobre você, sobre seus
hormônios, sua saúde, seu metabolismo,
seus exames, suplementos, sobre você.
Quer saber sobre jejum
dentro da nossa área de membros?
Entendido? E tudo que a gente tá fazendo
aqui tem embasamento científico. A minha
tese de conclusão em nutrologia,
meu TCC, foram 70 páginas sobre jejum
intermitente. Então, confie no que eu tô
falando. E quando eu comecei a falar
sobre jejum lá atrás, gente, nossa,
imagina, era um outro mundo, né? 12 anos
atrás falando sobre jejum,
11 anos atrás falando sobre jejum,
era um outro mundo. Mas novamente, o
jejum é uma das estratégias. Todas as
estratégias nutricionais funcionam. O
jejum é uma delas. E por que que o
desafio do jejum ele é tão incrível pra
saúde, para ativar seu emagrecimento?
Porque ele não é só sobre calorias, ele
vai ajudar a melhorar perfil de
insulina, tireoide, fígado, inflamação,
sono. Ui, seu corpo começa utilizar
gordura como fonte de energia, você
desincha, seu metabolismo aumenta por
conta disso. Então, quer perder peso, eu
preciso tratar os seus hormônios, eu
preciso tratar o seu metabolismo. E o
desafio do jejum vai trabalhar em todos
esses aspectos da sua saúde.
E agora eu quero que vocês preparem
print. Preparem print porque eu já quero
ensinar, mostrar para vocês três vias
iniciais para você ativar seu
metabolismo. Isso aqui você pode começar
a implementar hoje no seu dia. Então
existem três vias fundamentais pra gente
começar a emagrecer mais rápido. Claro,
existem muitas vias, mas hoje eu quero
te passar as três principais. Primeira
via de ativação metabólica, água. Eu fiz
uma pesquisa com vocês e mais de 70% das
mulheres que estão participando desse
desafio não bebem água, gente.
Então, existe uma técnica de água que se
você fizer, o seu metabolismo aumenta
30%. Se você beber 500 mA, gente, tira
print da tela, tá? Tira print. Prepara o
print. Tira print, tá? Tira print, ok?
Tira print.
Se você beber 500 ml de água de uma vez
a cada 2 horas, você mantém seu
metabolismo ativo em até 30% a mais. Não
existe termogênico no planeta, não
existe estimulante no planeta que
aumenta o metabolismo em 30%. Mas um
estudo japonês comprovou que se você
beber 500 ml de água, seu metabolismo
pode aumentar em até 30%. Então bebe.
Ah, mas preciso beber de gole. Não, vai
bebendo ali. É difícil. Tem gente que
não tá acostumado, mas você acostuma. Se
você beber água desse jeito, sendo que
você tem que bater três, tentar bater
2,5 L, 3 L no dia,
você vai hidratar seu corpo, vai
melhorar intestino, ajuda a te desinchar
e aumenta seu metabolismo em 30%.
Simples, de graça. Eu acabei de te
ensinar agora o melhor termogênico
gratuito que existe e melhor do que a
maioria dos termogênicos pagos que
existem. Outra estratégia dentro da
água, principalmente você que tá fazendo
jejum. Em jejum, o primeiro copo de
água, pitadinha de sal. Quem tem pressão
alta, não se preocupe. Você não vai
colocar uma colher de sopa, gente, é uma
pitada de sal. Isso vai aumentar
potencial de hidratação, vai ajudar a
evitar dor de cabeça no período de
jejum.
Quando você for quebrar o jejum antes da
primeira refeição, tenta colocar no copo
de água uma colher de sopa de vinagre de
maçã. Porque a maioria de vocês aqui tem
o quê? Tem um problema que chama
resistência insulínica. O vinagre de
maçã, ele vai diminuir em 50% o pico de
glicose e pico de insulina
e vai estimular todo o processo
digestivo.
Portanto, o jejum, ele vai ajudar não só
no emagrecimento, mas no controle
metabólico. Se você tem barriga, você
tem resistência à insulina. Amanhã a
gente vai falar mais sobre resistência
insulínica, tá?
Depois que você quebrar o jejum,
lembrando, isso aqui não é obrigatório,
é só para quem quiser implementar essas
estratégias, porque isso aqui traz um
gás a mais no seu resultado. Depois que
você quebrar o jejum, você pode colocar,
fazer uma pitadinha de cúrcuma com
pitada de pimenta preta ou pimenta
caiana. Isso, esse componente vai ter um
potencial anti-inflamatório
que vai ajudar na gordura visceral.
Quando nós falamos sobre gordura
visceral, que é a barriga, todo mundo
aqui que tem barriga tem gordura
visceral. E essa gordura visceral, ela
produz uma coisa chama citocina
inflamatória. E essa citocina
inflamatória precisa ser combatida.
Precisa ser combatida. E como que a
gente combate essa gordurinha visceral?
Com antioxidante.
Então, acabei de te ensinar agora um
tratamento que aumenta metabolismo, te
desincha, vai ajudar na saúde
intestinal, vai controlar a resistência
insulínica e vai ajudar a combater
gordura visceral. coisas simples e
realmente eficazes.
E lembrando, tudo que eu tô trazendo
aqui com comprovação e evidência
científica, não é achismo, é ciência na
sua forma mais simples aplicável para
vocês e mastigada, que é o que eu quero
entregar nesse nosso desafio.
Segunda via de ativação, gente, tira
print aqui, principalmente quem dorme
mal. Lembrando que nós teremos uma aula
nessa semana que eu vou falar tudo sobre
sono, tudo sobre sono. Mas já quero que
vocês comecem a implementar isso, porque
para perder peso, perder barriga, eu
preciso você dorme melhor. Eu preciso
que você dorme melhor. E um sono de alta
performance, ele regula leptina,
grelina, que são os hormônios da
saciedade da fome, vai te dar energia,
vai te dar disposição e se você dorme
melhor, você dobra a sua capacidade de
queima de gordura, principalmente
barriga. Quem dorme mal perde em torno
de 50% a capacidade de perder peso. E
como que você pode dormir melhor?
Primeiro, magnésio. Ao invés de pensar
em melatonina, como muitos profissionais
falam, não, gente, magnésio, magnésio,
glicina de 500 mg a 1 g de magnésio
glicina, melhora a qualidade do sono.
Você pode fazer chá de mulungu com
camomila, uma colher de sopa de mulungu
com camomila,
faz o chazinho à noite e evita a luz
azul de celular 2 horas antes de dormir.
Isso vai ajustar o ciclo circadiano do
seu sono. E quando você acordar de
manhã, toma seu cafezinho olhando pra
luz do dia. Não precisa ser o sol no
rosto, pode ser a luz do dia. Isso vai
ativar o ciclo circadiano do sono. Tirou
print? Tirou print.
Terceira via de ativação do metabolismo.
Tira print dessa tela aqui também. Tira
print dessa tela aqui também.
Alguém perguntou sobre o tempo dessas
aulas. Gente, essas aulas aqui tem em
média 60 minutos. Tudo bem, meninas? Às
vezes eu passo um pouquinho, às vezes
menos. Às vezes eu entrego mais coisa. É
assim, vem aqui da cabeça, tá gente?
Viu?
Agora aqui, ó,
tira print disso aqui, porque eu preciso
ativar a via de aumento de energia de
vocês. Aumento de energia,
porque existe uma coisa que é a
mitocôndria. A mitocôndria é o motor das
nossas células.
E eu preciso dar suplemento para isso,
para você ter mais energia, mais
exposição, pro seu metabolismo ficar
ativo. E tem uma forma muito simples de
você ativar energia. Tem um chá que é um
dos poucos chás que aumenta o
metabolismo, que é o chá de long, você
pode tomar de manhã,
ou chá verde.
Mas se você utilizar café com
colherzinha de cacau e canela, mas aí
não pode ser no período de jejum, tem
que ser depois que você quebrar o jejum,
porque o cacau e a canela vão quebrar o
jejum.
Esse café com colherzinha de cacau e
canela, pode colocar cravo também,
funciona como um antidepressivo natural
e vai te dar energia, vai te dar um bush
de energia.
E quem se sente muito fadigada, pode ser
utilizado um outro tipo de chá. Você que
mesmo dormindo se sente cansada, você
pode utilizar um outro tipo de chá que é
o chá de jin 100. O chá de jin 100 ele
modula sua fadiga. Então você pode de
manhã fazer um chá de jinem com chá
verde junto ou chá de long com jinem.
Uma colherzinha de chá de cada. Vai te
jogar para cima, vai te trazer um
bem-estar. E depois que você fizer sua
primeira refeição do dia, pode colocar
um pouquinho de cacau com canela no seu
café, que isso funciona como
antidepressivo, um anciolítico natural,
nutrindo mitocôndria e perfil
energético.
E foi exatamente isso que a gente fez
com a Jéssica. A Jéssica, aluna do PEF,
ela não conseguia perder peso e ela
falou: "Tor Renan, não consigo perder
barriga". Gente, quem tem barriga assim
tem resistência insulínica e tem
provavelmente alteração de cortisol,
porque a gordura abdominal ela tem
receptor para insulina e cortisol com
hormônio de estresse. E eu falei,
Jéssica, a gente precisa controlar tudo
isso. A gente precisa ativar as vias de
queima de gordura, você precisa beber
água direito, a gente precisa cuidar do
metabolismo. Ela não podia fazer
atividade física. E quando a gente
tratou tudo isso, toda a base, toda a
causa raiz, 10 kg em 45 dias é ao todo
22 kg.
E vocês, para terem resultados
duradouros e perderem muito mais quilos
do que vocês vão perder nesse nosso
desafio, vocês precisam entender sobre a
escada do sucesso do emagrecimento
definitivo, que é isso daqui. Olha só.
Então vocês hoje nesse nosso desafio
vocês estão no primeiro degrau que é o
degrau da ativação metabólica. Você tá
aqui o desafio do jejum 5 e7. vocês vão
caus fazer esse reset no metabolismo de
vocês. E ao longo da semana eu vou
mostrar como que vocês passam para
segundo, pro segundo degrau, porque o
segundo degrau é ajuste completo de base
hormonal metabólica. E depois para vocês
terem essa independência, esse esse essa
manutenção do seu emagrecimento, então
todo o emagrecimento ele deve ter ser
construído a partir desses degraus aqui.
E vocês estão no primeiro degrau que vai
ser construído nesse nosso desafio.
Porque vocês só estão aqui porque vocês
cometem cinco erros da tentativa de
emagrecer
e toda vez que vocês tentam emagrecer,
vocês vão por esses caminhos errados. E
quais são esses erros? Primeiro erro,
dieta restritiva. Você vai lá, faz dieta
maluca, metabolismo cai, peso cai, você
fica animada, de repente estagna. Só que
cada vez que você sofre com efeito
sanfona, você cria, você piora a
resistência insulínica. Quantas vezes na
sua vida você já criou, já teve efeito
sanfona?
É, em quantas vezes na sua vida você já
sofreu com efeito sanfona? Muitas vezes.
E você piora o grau de resistência
insulínica.
E quando você faz uma dieta muito
restrita, piora a função da tireoide. E
aí vira um efeito dominó do seu
metabolismo que você não tem controle.
Lembra que eu falei?
Você não tem culpa do peso que você tá.
Você só tentou construir emagrecimento
de uma forma errada e você não escolheu
ter problema de tireoide, de insulina,
cortisol, sono de má qualidade,
intestino. Não foi uma escolha sua. Isso
aconteceu com você. Isso aconteceu com
você. Segundo erro, profissionais
tradicionais. Você vai lá, passa uma
hora de consulta. Eu já fui esse
profissional lá atrás. Eles olham seus
exames, fala que tá tudo bem com você,
te passa uma dieta, um remédio. E existe
hoje uma burrice coletiva na internet
que a maioria dos profissionais falam
que o que importa é caloria para
emagrecer. Caloria importa sim, muito,
mas não é só isso. Para você emagrecer,
a gente tem que ter um controle de
caloria, sim. Mas que que os
profissionais falam na internet? Ah, se
você consumiu uma maçã e um brigadeiro
tem a mesma quantidade de caloria.
Só que se você tem resistência
insulínica, o brigadeiro e açúcar causa
pico de insulina. Insulina sobe quando
você come carboidrato, açúcar, massas,
pães, biscoitos, bolachas. Então você
engorda também por um mecanismo
hormonal. A maçã não vai causar o pico
de insulina. Então precisam entender o
seu perfil hormonal para saber o tipo de
alimentação que você pode consumir
naquele momento. E os profissionais, por
isso que você vai no nutre, às vezes não
tem resultado nenhum e ele ainda culpa
você. fala que você é culpada, que você
deve ter comido errado, mas não, você
tentou, eu acredito que você come pouco.
Terceiro erro que você comete na
tentativa de emagrecer, atividade
física.
Gente, quem disse que a atividade física
vai aumentar muito seu metabolismo?
Atividade física representa só 5% na
perda de peso. Não tô falando que não é
importante paraa qualidade de vida, para
longividade saudável, mas atividade
física não vai tratar seus hormônios
e representa só 5% no processo de perda
de peso. E quem não pode fazer, quem tem
problema de joelho, quem tem algum
problema de locomoção, essas pessoas não
vão emagrecer nunca.
Esse é o ponto. Atividade física só
representa 5% no processo de perda de
peso. Quarto erro que vocês cometem,
remédios. Aí vocês vão lá, usam o pique,
munjaro, já utilizaram muitas medicações
e o que que acontece? Risco pra saúde,
são caros, você não vai conseguir manter
isso para sempre. E quando você para,
mais de 90% das pessoas depois que param
tem reganho de peso.
Esses medicamentos não tratam sua
tireoide, não tratam seu sono, não
tratam seu intestino, aliás, até prendem
mais o intestino. Quem é que já usou o
remédio e engordou mais depois, hein?
Quem aqui já utilizou?
Quem aqui?
Alguém perguntou aqui, ó. Quem tem
gastrite, pangastrite?
Eh, esofagite, pode usar o vinagre de
maçã em jejum. Gente, esse vinagre de
maçã é tomar e comer imediatamente.
Quem aqui, hein, meninas? Ó lá, tem
efeito sofona já várias vezes.
Engordei mais. Alguém falou aqui.
E é isso.
E o quinto erro, cirurgias
emagrecedoras. Eu sei que muitos de
vocês já fizeram bariátrica. Se você já
fez bariátrica, você consegue emagrecer
como qualquer mulher,
como qualquer pessoa, você consegue
perder peso, mas muitas aqui ainda não
fizeram, tem a cirurgia como uma luz no
fim do túnel, mas quase todo mundo que
faz bariátrica tem regran de peso, sem
contar deficiências nutricionais,
todos os problemas que implicam essa
cirurgia. Alguém que já fez bariátrica,
teve reganho de peso? Ó lá, ó. Teve
aqui, ó, fiz bariátrica, teve regulho de
peso. Sim, é isso. Esse é o ponto. E aí
quando a pessoa faz bariátrica
e ela engorda de novo, ela acha: "Meu
Deus, eu já fiz realmente de tudo, então
não tem jeito para mim". Tem sim, calma.
vai dar certo, porque você vai conseguir
emagrecer como qualquer mulher por conta
dos seus hormônios, por conta de
metabolismo, por conta de alimentação.
Vai dar tudo certo. Então não tem essa
esse pensamento na sua cabeça, porque
amanhã, gente, na aula dois, hoje, né, a
gente aprendeu sobre os erros, algumas
formas de ativar o metabolismo, demos
uma passada no jejum, contei um pouco de
como foi criado esse método, mas amanhã,
na aula dois eu vou falar tudo sobre
dietas, tudo sobre seus hormônios e como
começar a tratar. E a gente vai começar
a vencer medos, ansiedades, traumas e
uma mente forte. Amanhã na aula dois a
gente vai falar tudo sobre isso. E foi
exatamente isso que a gente fez com a
Dalva. Olha só a Dalva, gente. Quem tem
barriga assim? A Dalva, 51 anos de
idade, as pessoas perguntavam se ela
tava grávida.
Essa é uma barriga de gordura visceral.
Tá vendo que ela tem um aspecto mais
endurecido?
Barriga de gordura visceral. Quem tem
uma barriga assim tem resistência
insulínica, alteração de função de
fígado. Se altera fígado, diminui função
dos hormônios, conversão de hormônio de
tireoide. Então você começa a ter todo
um um metabolismo muito lento
e você acha que é só o peso o problema.
O peso é o problema superficial, é a
pontinha do iceberg, mas o que tá
embaixo é aí que tá o segredo do seu
emagrecimento acelerado, saudável e a
manutenção do do peso depois. E aí eu te
pergunto, por que que seu metabolismo é
lento?
Não é por causa de idade, não é por
causa de menopausa. Seu metabolismo é
lento por conta de anos de tentativas. E
esses anos de tentativas fizeram você
ter uma tireoide desregulada, você ter
um um sono ruim, um intestino ruim,
cortes alterado, leptina, grelina,
hormônio de saciedade, hormônios
sexuais. E isso você não tem controle. E
se você toma purã, levo cintroide ou
tirox, leva tiroxina, remete tireoide,
você precisa repor o T3 junto com seu
reméreoide, sen não são perde peso. E eu
vou te falar sobre isso numa aula de
tireoide que a gente vai fazer tudo
sobre tireoide, insulino, acho que na
quarta, acho que na quarta.
E aí eu te pergunto, por que que você
não consegue manter seu emagrecimento?
Porque você só busca emagrecer cometendo
aqueles cinco erros, com medicação, com
dietinha, cortando alimentação, comendo
muito pouco. E essa não é a forma
correta de construir emagrecimento.
Mas hoje eu quero liberar para vocês a
nossa primeira chave secreta. E essa
primeira chave secreta,
a nossa primeira chave secreta.
Sabe o que que acontece? Ela tem relação
com a sua análise.
Ela tem relação com a sua análise.
Hoje você vai ter uma análise completa
dos seus sintomas. Lembrando, cada uma
das aulas eu vou liberar o quê? chaves
secretas aqui para vocês.
E a nossa primeira chave secreta é um
mapa do seu emagrecimento.
E esse mapa do emagrecimento, a gente
vai fazer um mapeamento de todos os seus
sintomas. Deixa eu mostrar como que é o
mapa do emagrecimento para vocês. Então,
esse material que vai ser liberado para
vocês, tem toda a forma. O que que é
esse mapa, para que que ele serve? a
forma de você preencher. Então aqui, ó,
principalmente nessa tabela aqui, nessa
tabela
vocês vão ter lá a primeira coluna, onde
tem 1 2 3 4 5, depois a segunda coluna
dos sintomas e a terceira coluna você
vai dar uma nota de zero a quatro, uma
nota de zero a quatro, onde zero você
não tem aquele sintoma e quatro você tem
muito daquele sintoma.
E depois lá na última coluna você vai
colocar a soma de cada sessão, de cada
setor. Deixa eu preencher o mapa aqui
junto com vocês. Então aqui meninas,
vamos lá.
Então olha só, você vai colocar uma
nota, vou dando exemplo ali, ó. Quatro
tem muito sintoma,
dois mais ou menos, três mais ou menos.
Três um pouco mais desse sintoma. E aí
você vai pegar e colocar a soma desse
setor. Ó lá o setor. A soma deu 12.
Depois de um exemplo ali, ó, dois, a
soma 20, depois 15, depois 15. E lá
embaixo você vai colocar.
E depois que você colocar toda a soma,
todos os números, lá embaixo, você
coloca a soma. E aí essa soma vai ser a
pontuação do seu mapa. Lá, ó, teve gente
já preencheu. Pontuação, deu 73, deu 46,
deu deu 65. Eita, 58. Alta. E qual a
relação da pontuação do seu mapa com a
sua saúde?
Isso daqui. Tira print da tela aqui,
gente. Tira print da tela. Tira pr print
da tela.
Se a pontuação do seu mapa deu menor do
que 10, então a sua saúde está em
alerta.
Você tem um perfil hormonal sentinela.
Vocês preencheram aquele nosso nosso
questionáriozinho. Você já recebeu o seu
perfil hormonal? Você tá com perfil
hormonal sentinela.
Alguém aqui já identificou seu perfil
hormonal? Se você é sentinela, refém,
sobrecarregada, prisioneira, coloca aqui
no chat para mim se você já identificou
qual que é seu perfil. Se a sua
pontuação for maior que 10, a sua saúde
já tá em desequilíbrio e você está refém
desse desequilíbrio, só que você não
consegue ainda perceber direito o que
que tá acontecendo. Se a sua pontuação
foi maior que 20, saúde ruim,
você está sobrecarregada. O seu sistema
metabólico, ele tá com várias
sobrecargas e isso afeta a sua saúde. Se
a sua pontuação maior do que 40, saúde
muito ruim e você tá prisioneira.
Prisioneira. Então aqui, ó, comenta
aqui, ó. Vocês já estão mandando
torrefém, prisioneira. Se você não fez,
é só fazer hoje, tá em tempo, viu,
meninas? Ninguém tá atrasada, não. Eu
quero que eu quero agora, quando eu
aparecer aqui o seu perfil, tira print
da tela para você depois dar uma
lidinha. O que que é? Se você tá no
perfil Sentinela, o Sentinela é uma
armadilha, porque parece que sua saúde
tá boa, mas não tá. Você já começa que a
roupa começou a marcar diferente, a
barriguinha aparecendo, os seus exames
parecem que tá tudo bem, mas na verdade
o peso não cai e você sente que alguma
coisa tá mudando, tá ficando um
pouquinho mais cansada, né? As coisas
começam a ficar um pouquinho mais
difícil, difíceis, e daí você acha que é
o quê? idade, que é menopausa, ah, que é
assim, e você se acostuma, como os
sintomas não são tão aparentes, você
acha que é normal, mas aqui é o momento,
seu corpo tá te mandando sinal antes que
o problema apareça. Então, você chegou
no momento certo de de cuidar disso.
Agora, a refém, quem aqui tá a refém?
A refém é aquela pessoa que faz dieta,
come pouco, corta carboidrato, se
esforça de verdade, mas a balança quase
não muda.
Você continua mais inchadinha, o braço
engordou pouquinho, a gordurinha das
costas tá aumentando, aí te dá, bate uma
sensação, né? Ai meu Deus, uma
preguicinha, um desânimo.
Você tenta, tenta, tenta. E não é falta
de força de vontade, porque você tenta.
Só que o seu metabolismo ele tá
segurando, seu metabolismo ele tá
atrapalhando seu emagrecimento.
Só que aqui a gente já consegue
identificar o que que tá acontecendo com
o seu corpo.
Quem é aqui é sobrecarregada e qual o
perfil sobrecarregado?
Então, a pessoa que tá sobrecarregada,
que tá com uma pontuação de 20 a 40
pontos, essa pessoa, ela já tem um
cansaço que não passa nem dormindo, você
já tem sintomas aparentes, uma vontade
de doce, vontade de carboidrato, você
não consegue se controlar. A pessoa que
tá sobrecarregada já pensou às vezes em
até abandonar o processo de saúde,
emagrecimento para tentar se aceitar do
jeito que ela tá
e você fica frustrada porque você tenta,
você vai em médico, você vai nutre, você
controla, só que você continua, você tá
cheio de sintoma, cansado, ansiosa, com
baixa autoestima, o eixo fígado,
insulina, tireoide já começa a ficar em
desequilíbrio, então você já começa a
ter muitos problemas hormonais aqui.
Então, nesse momento,
o tempo já tá contra você, porque
existem doenças que podem se instalar se
você não cuidar.
Entendido?
Agora, sobre a prisioneira.
A prisioneira a saúde muito ruim.
Você já sabe que sua saúde tá ruim.
Então esse perfil tá ligado a uma base
hormonal metabólica totalmente
comprometida.
Você não dorme bem, você vive no efeito
sanfona, tem barriga, cansada, ansiosa,
deprimida, unha fraca, queda de cabelo,
metabolismo lento, você dorme, mas
acorda, até dorme, mas acorda cansada, o
intestino já não funciona bem. Então
você tá com comprometimento global da
sua saúde.
E esse comprometimento global global da
sua saúde, novamente, não é falta de
força de vontade. Você já tem um
comprometimento de saúde mais grave e
isso precisa ser tratado, porque senão
daqui a pouco responde o quê? Em outras
doenças, doenças autoimunes, diabetes,
alteração da sua saúde de forma global.
E isso precisa ser cuidado, não só
pensando em quilos, pensando em reverter
um quadro que pode piorar lá na frente,
não muito lá na frente, muito em breve.
E isso não foi construído nas últimas
semanas, foi construído, esse problema
foi construído nos últimos anos.
E por mais que você já tenha tentado de
tudo, vários profissionais de saúde,
você já tenha tentado vários remédios,
várias dietas, nada sustenta, porque
existe um componente da sua saúde
hormonal
totalmente debilitado.
Totalmente debilitado.
Gue falou que a prisioneira é igual,
detonada.
Mas a boa notícia é que independente do
perfil que você esteja, se você está no
perfil sentinela, se você está no perfil
refém, onde você já começa a ter um
metabolismo travado, fígado travado,
independente se você tá na
sobrecarregada que ainda já tem um
comprometimento real, ou você que tá
prisioneira, que realmente já tem
problemas instalados, todos têm
reversão, todos têm tratamento. E o
segredo aqui é o grau de comprometimento
da sua base hormonal metabólica. E onde
você encontra? Aqui essa daqui, lá na
área de membros, você vai encontrar a
chave secreta aqui debaixo da aula.
Sempre vai ter um botão para você baixar
a chave secreta. E dentro da nossa área
de membros tem o acesso para você para
você fazer o seu teste, tá bom? lá onde
tá aquela nossa parte da da carta para
você fazer o teste, para você descobrir.
E quando você preenche o seu mapa e tem
a sua pontuação do mapa, com a pontuação
do mapa, você sabe qual o seu perfil
hormonal.
Alguém pediu volta na tela da
prisioneira aqui, ó. Tela prisioneira.
Tira print, viu? Tira print.
Deixa eu colocar então. Vamos lá. Tira
print. Todo mundo tá pedindo. Vamos
mostrar todas.
Vamos lá. Tira print da tela aí, tá,
meninas? A sentinela,
a refém.
Quem é refém? Tira print da tela.
Agora sobrecarregada
e
a prisioneira.
Onde faço o mapa? Acabei de mostrar. Ele
tá dentro da área de membros, debaixo da
aula.
Se a sua pontuação menor que 10,
sentinela. Se a sua pontuação maior que
10, refém. Se a sua pontuação do mapa
maior que 20, sobrecarregada. Se a sua
pontuação do mapa maior que 40, você
está no perfil
prisioneira.
Entendido?
Agora, o que que vocês vão fazer para
mudar esse perfil? Ao longo dessa
semana, eu vou te passando todo o
tratamento para mudar cada um desse
perfil.
onde você encontra o mapa para você
poder baixar. Na área de membros lá do
do nosso desafio, vai ter um botão verde
debaixo do link da primeira aula para
você baixar o seu mapa.
E quem tá na aula ganha bônus, hein,
meninas. Então, essa foi a primeira, o
mapa do emagrecimento foi a nossa
primeira chave secreta. Só que quem tá
na aula ganha o quê? O bônus que vai ser
hoje é um bônus do nosso protocolo
Acelera metabolismo, que é o elixir
dourado anti barriga. O que que é esse
elixir dourado antibarriga? Deixa eu
mostrar para vocês.
Elixir dourado antibarriga. O que que é
isso? Somente para quem vier nas aulas,
eu libero bônus. Cada aula vai ter um
bônus e no final você vai ter um
protocolo completo, acelera metabolismo.
Então esse elixir dourado antibarriga
tem alguns suplementos e a forma, deixa
eu mostrar assim, tem alguns componentes
e aqui, ó, toda a forma de você
implementar esse elixir dourado
antibarriga para acelerar metabolismo,
você perder barriga mais rápido e com
potencial antiinflamatório te desinchar.
É sensacional isso daqui. esse material
completo para vocês, com coisas simples
que vocês conseguem aplicar hoje já no
dia a dia de vocês. E como que você
acessa esse nosso elixir dourado
antibarriga?
Sabe como?
Cada um, ao final de cada aula, nós
teremos o quê? A lista de presença. A
lista de presença. É importante que você
preencha a lista de presença cada dia
das aulas, porque quem preenche a lista
de presença, a gente vai sortear para
quem preenche a lista de presença um kit
de suplementos. Mas no final da lista de
presença, só para quem preenche a lista
de presença, vai ter o link para você,
vai ter o link para você baixar direto o
nosso elixir dourado antibarriga.
Elixir dourado antibarriga, só para quem
liberar. E assim, cada uma das aulas eu
vou liberando bônus, um melhor do que o
outro. Isso aqui é muito legal, muito
legal.
Ó, outra coisa, ele vai ficar disponível
só agora, então você tem que preencher
sua lista de presença agora, porque
depois a gente não permite mais. É para
quem tá na aula, viu? Então você que tá
aqui na aula, preenche lista de
presença. Final da lista de presença,
vai ter o link para você poder baixar,
só para quem tiver ao vivo. Depois não
tem como baixar mais. Perfeito. Então
lista de link de presença tá aqui na
aula, a gente vai colocar no chat para
vocês e fica depois também na descrição
da da aula. Uma outra coisa aqui, gente,
que tá rolando nessa semana é assim:
nós temos sempre desafios, tá rolando,
então vocês preencham a lista de
presença e no final vai ter o presente
para vocês poderem baixar. Mas eu tenho
um desafio para vocês e quem participa
desse desafio
ganha pontos para participar do concurso
que vai rolar no final da semana. Então,
o seguinte, ó. Deixa eu postar,
ó. Eu vou postar essa foto aqui agora lá
no meu perfil do Instagram. Essa foto
aqui vai ficar vai ficar lá no meu
perfil do Instagram, esta foto aqui. OK?
E nessa foto, eu quero que vocês vão lá
nessa foto e coloca para mim o que que
vocês acharam dessa aula. Mas vocês vão
colocar essa hashtag. Cada uma das aulas
nós teremos uma hashtag. #enovvalor
#utenvalor
Então eu vou postar essa foto no meu
perfil do Instagram e eu quero que vocês
vão lá e coloqu #uutenho valor e coloca
o que que foi mais importante nessa aula
hoje para você, nessa nossa aula um. E a
gente tá só começando. A gente tá só
começando,
OK? Então, qual a importância de vocês
irem
escreverem isso aqui para mim? Porque
olha, quando vocês escrevem, isso se
manifesta na sua vida. Isso é comprovado
tanto pela neurociência e tá lá na
Bíblia, gente, em Abacuk. Tudo que você
escreve se manifesta na sua vida.
E quando você escreve, você ativa vários
sentidos, visual,
tátil, e você instala isso no seu
cérebro, porque você tem valor, mesmo
não estando no peso que você quer. Você
tem valor mesmo não estando com o corpo
que você quer ainda. Então, existe uma
mulher dentro de você, por mais que você
não se reconheça, que tem valor. Se você
construir o seu emagrecimento só na
autocrítica, na autodestruição, não se
amando, não se gostando, quando você
emagrecer, você vai continuar olhando só
defeito em você. Então, hoje vocês têm
um desafio
lá no post, me conta o que que vocês
acharam da aula, porque a aula de amanhã
vai ser ainda melhor do que essa. Então,
#enho
valor na nosso no nosso post que vai
ficar fixado lá no meu perfil do
Instagram. Então, estão desafiadas.
Por que que vocês têm que ir lá nesse
post? Primeiro que nós temos prêmios e
sorteios que vão acontecer ao longo
dessa semana. Prêmio, gente. A, não é
escrever presente aqui no chat não, viu?
Vocês têm que clicar no link. A gente
vai colocar o link aqui para vocês. A
gente vai colocar o link aqui. Vocês t
que entrar no link, não é escrever
presente aqui. É nesse link aí que vocês
conseguem baixar baixar o
vocês conseguem baixar o material. A
gente já vai colocar o link aqui para
vocês. Deixa eu só dar esse recado, por
quem preenche todas as listas de
presença e você que vai lá no nosso post
da aula e coloca #utenhovalor,
você vai participar, tem que preencher
todas as listas de presença de todas as
aulas. Vai lá nesse post e coloca porque
isso conta pontinhos. Eu vou sortear um
kit de suplementos. Isso aqui não tá à
venda, são suplementos desenvolvidos por
mim. Esse aqui é a pílula do pãozinho. A
pílula do pãozinho é uma fórmula
desenvolvida por mim que atrapalha a
absorção de uma refeição livre. Então,
por exemplo, vai comer uma pizza com sua
família, toma a pílula do pãozinho, ela
vai atrapalhar a absorção de parte dessa
pizza. Gelzinho dos sonhos, que ajuda na
libido feminina e o fitoterápico para
energia e que também ajuda na libido
feminina. Então assim, kits de
suplementos desenvolvidos por mim, a
gente vai sortear para você participar
do sorteio, você tem que preencher todas
as listas de presenças. E temos o
concurso, gente. Vamos lá. Eu quero que
vocês, para participar do concurso que
tá rolando nessa semana, vocês tem que
tirar. Vocês se pesaram, né? se pesar,
saber o peso de vocês. Saber o peso de
vocês. E eu quero que vocês tirem foto.
Tira foto de vocês de frente, de lado,
de costas,
porque no final da semana para
participar do concurso que tá rolando. E
esse concurso vale uma vaga de
acompanhamento mais completo, que é o
PEF 360, meu programa mais completo e
também é o kit suplementos.
Preciso saber toda a transformação no
final da semana, os quilos que você
perdeu e tira foto de frente, de lado,
de costas, porque no final de semana
você também vai mandar foto de frente,
de lado e de costas.
Então vamos lá. Sorteio vai acontecer na
nossa última aula, o sorteio de
suplementos. Para participar, você tem
que preencher todas as listas de
presença e tem que ir lá nos nossos
posts colocar a hashtag daaula. Hoje a
hashagutenovalor
e temos o concurso que vai ser liberado
no final da semana. Vai concorrer quem
preencher lista de presença, quem
realizar a tarefa que vai ser liberada
lá no final da semana e prêmio, análise
individualizada do mapa e do
emagrecimento feita por mim, o meu kit
de suplementos e vaga garantida no PEF
360, que é o meu programa de
emagrecimento feminino mais completo com
meu acompanhamento. Portanto, meninas,
que que vocês têm que fazer hoje?
preencher a lista de presença para você
poder baixar o elixir antibarriga, se
programar paraa aula de amanhã e você
tem que ir onde? no nosso post do
Instagram, aqui, ó, nesse post lá do
Instagram, colocar hashagut valor,
porque a aula dois amanhã,
opa, pera aí,
porque a aula dois amanhã 7 horas da
manhã tá ainda melhor. Vou te mostrar os
pilares do emagrecimento. Opa. Vou te
mostrar os pilares do emagrecimento
definitivo, passos pro metabolismo
sempre ativo, técnicas para ativar seu
metabolismo. Vou te entregar a segunda
chave. secreta, mas análise do seu mapa
e o segundo bônus vai ser liberado para
quem tiver na aula. Então o link estará
aqui no chat agora que a gente vai
colocar aqui. Entendido, meninas? Bom,
vejo vocês amanhã
na nossa segunda aula que vai ser ainda
melhor do que essa. O perfil
@renanbotelhodr.
@renambanotelhodr.
O link está no chat. O link tá no chat.
o link de presença, meninas, um beijo
para vocês. Vejo vocês. Então, tô de
olho lá no post, vocês me contando o que
que acharam da aula, porque isso conta
pontinhos na hora da gente escolher a
campeã do concurso. Dica tá dada.
Beijo, meninas. Mais uma vez, muito
obrigado pela presença de todas. Vejo
vocês amanhã na aula dois, que aí a
gente começa a entender sobre seus
hormônios, seu metabolismo, sobre dieta,
sobre tudo, tá bom? Beijo, meninas. Vejo
vocês amanhã.